so listen so many of you are focused on
getting your Tick Tock right and you've
all been holding on to your Instagram
every one of you are holding onto your
Instagram way too much holding on for
your life as your organic reach declines
and meanwhile Facebook reels is going
crazy this is a very simple Monday
morning [__] video I said it subtly
in a lot of posts but get your [__]
Facebook wheels on what's that dude I'm
at the airport it's late as [__] but
listen to me Facebook [__] reels you
hear me get on it get on it quickly
start adding into your rotation it's
[__] working for a lot of people and
that makes me happy I really really
I prefer what you [__] win I'm gonna
I'd like for you to add Facebook reels
to your repertoire it's working